Yeah,
well my advice is really to follow your
passion.
I mean study something that interests
you but also qualifies you to apply.
It's a,
as I said,
NASA recruits from a wide variety of
backgrounds.
You have to have a bachelor's degree at
least in science or engineering.
But,
uh,
pick the field that you like,
you know,
um,
I know people who have applied to be
astronauts who,
who asked me,
well,
should I do this,
should I do that?
And I said,
you don't,
it doesn't matter.
The basic requirements are you have to
be in good health and you have to have a
good heart.
I mean,
in a technical way,
not so much be a kind person while,
although that helps.
But,
um,
you know,
study something that you like and do
well in it.